[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Frances roster on constants in Kissin
and this is a show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our fantastic guests this week didn't
want to be introduced as an expert what
we think she'll be absolutely
fascinating to talk to
she's the campaign manager at the
Taxpayers Alliance Chloe Wesley
welcome to trigonometry thanks for
having me
[Music]
it's great to have you and before we get
on with the show just tell us a little
bit about who you are how did you get to
where you are and maybe a little bit
about kind of your thoughts and your
background how you developed your ideas
and your views well I'm from Australia
originally as people find out when they
see me on TV they're like what's that
accent I'm from Brisbane and Queensland
I didn't grow up wanting to be a
campaign manager for a tax organization
that wasn't really part of the plan I
was just very very interested in
politics I'm a very young age I was a
complete nerd at school I remember
actually being picked on a little bit
for being a bit obsessed with politics
because I was always reading newspapers
and watching political shows it was
quite an odd obsession that I had and my
parents like wide it has come from is it
was just a natural thing that I was
really interested in so as I was reading
as a young person developing my thoughts
I was very open to lots of different
ideas but I was about 16 I think I was a
little bit more left-wing than I am now
so I thought the world was really unfair
there were some people that were
struggling and others that were doing
really well and I I was very skeptical
of Authority and of the system and I
read a lot of you know French and German
philosophy and I read this book by
Albert Camus called the rebel where he
writes about revolutions and he wrote
about the Soviet Union and it changed a
lot of my thinking about things because
he pointed out the flaws in his thinking
and that he was a left-wing person he
wanted to empower people but he saw that
when you do have socialist and communist
regimes actually people can become
enslaved you just give power you just
transfer power to a state and actually
that's a different kind of enslavement
so it made me very skeptical of statist
ideologies and actually I became a lot
more fond of the idea of individualism
and that people societies where people
are free and they have the most freedom
to choose things are far more prosperous
and and people thrive a lot more than in
societies where there is a really big
state and so those that's kind of how my
views developed but I moved to London
and to study philosophy just after high
school so when I was about 18 and I
really got to engage a lot of these
ideas on a deeper level and I met some
incredible philosophers I was very lucky
I went to a philosophy College so we had
12 different professors and experts in
all different kinds of areas and I did
read a lot of Marx I was fascinated I
think he identified a problem but
proposed a completely wrong solution in
my opinion I fell in love with Aristotle
Greek philosophy and I just I really
loved ideas and I became very interested
in British politics over here because
everyone was talking about this and
everyone was talking about the European
Union and that was from a very early
time and I moved here I remember that
was already part of the national
conversation at least in in the common
room and and students talking about
these things and I didn't really set out
to get into politics over here in my at
the end of my second year University I
volunteered for an MP to help him get
elected on the conservative side and
then completely unexpectedly well I was
still a student he offered me a job and
that was life-changing because instead
of just reading about politics and
debating it online and watching question
time and shouting at the TV I was I was
actually I got to be part of it I got to
work in Parliament it was incredible and
I felt very very lucky and also a little
bit surprised that you know from growing
up in Queensland to working in the
British Parliament it wasn't really an
obvious thing for me to turn out to do
so that was incredible I feel very lucky
to have that experience and even working
in Parliament I was still reading and
studying and learning more about the EU
and I became very severely Euroskeptic I
mean one of the reasons why I wanted to
work for this MP was because he was very
skeptic at the time because it was my
skepticism of you know centralized
control taking control away from the
individual and every the more I read
about that you the more I thought hang
on this is a really really bad thing for
this country and even though this wasn't
the country I'm born and this is a
country
her family and history and you know I
just felt like the country was moving in
their own direction so I was very
passionate about it and I got to work on
the the leave campaign something that I
really really wanted to do and that was
incredible I didn't think we were going
to win the referendum but I thought we'd
come pretty close and I wanted to stake
a claim in that fight if there was going
to be this referendum in Britain at a
time when I was living here I wanted to
have it known that I was on the side of
the the anti the EU side and that was
incredible and from there I helped
launch another brick suit group after
the referendum to hold treason made to
account geezer Stuart's Labour MP she's
fantastic one of my heroes well the next
MP now she stood down and now I work at
the Taxpayers Alliance which is very
much in line with my kind of skepticism
of government and of you know
centralized power I think people are tax
way too much in this country I think in
general there is a move towards you know
more spending more governments whenever
there's a problem in society the first
thought of most politicians and most
commentators is how can the government
solve it so we've got a problem with you
know childhood obesity kids eating too
much sugar how the government must do
something
the government must introduce a sugar
tax this is the kind of in a way of
thinking and Westminster at the moment
and the organization I work for we're in
the minority we're the group saying hang
on maybe every problem society isn't
solved by a big government spending
money and taxing people maybe
individuals commit choices maybe there
are free market solutions to these
things so open with the taxpayers Lance
for about a year and I'm loving it I'm
not loving the criticism because it's
it's very brave to go out and argue for
lower taxes in the current climate yeah
I think so I think I'm I'm always
outnumbered and all the shows that I do
remember I did any questions and there
was two MPs and a priest socialist
priest lovely lovely lovely chap and
they were all talking about the cost of
living and how the government can solve
it and I said well what about taking
less money away from people so they have
water sprays balloon come and they all
laughed at me it is it is a
non-conventional
viewpoint at the moment well that's
great well we love to have people with
non-commercial hue points on the show
and so what does the Taxpayers Alliance
do we'll come to the BRICS it breaks it
in a bit what do you do with the
Taxpayers Alliance do you campaign do
you advocate to government do Lobby
government to change things how do you
try and make change to society well we
try and connect activists to government
and also speak for taxpayers so the
taxpayers Lance was founded in 2004 by a
couple of guys and Joe Elam and Matthew
Elliott and at the time every politician
every political party was calling for
higher taxes and more spending and there
was a lot of lobbying in Parliament in
Westminster for more money so charities
would lobby for more money different
pressure groups there wasn't really a
pressure group or a group representing
taxpayers the people that are paying for
all these things they set up this group
I think mostly just put pressure on
political parties to think about
taxpayers and their right policy
actually and just expose how much
government spending there is what it's
being spent on and point out some areas
where money can be saved so at the
moment we're pretty small organizations
still but we get a lot of press
attention because I think we have a
unique viewpoint at the moment in
Westminster and we do a lot we do
reports on what the taxes and should
look like so in 2012 we released the
single income tax which outlined how
would we would simplify taxes and what
areas are spending we would cut and what
they're kind of perfect Britain would
look like not a perfect Britain but
where where the country could go and
it's very practical it was you know
government spending should be about a
third of GDP and taxes on income should
be about 33% and figured out you know
all the numbers and all the way that the
government could move towards this
position at the moment government
spending is about 40 percent and if
you're lower earner you're taxed at
about a rate of about 40 percent and if
you're a higher earner the tax rate is
53 percent so we've got a long way to go
to get to that vision but we do a lot of
local
work so the things that people don't
really see the taxpayers do the
taxpayers Alliance do is all of our
local campaigning so we do national
press releases and reports and we go on
political shows but the day-to-day work
a lot of it is just local activists
calls and says I think Monica council
spending money on this thing can you
help me set up a stand so I can protest
it or can you tell me the person I can
get in touch with to change this so at
the moment would be a campaign in South
Hampton because they want to introduce
this new surcharges clean air zone
surcharge so if you want to drive into
them and you go to pay a hundred pounds
which is essentially attacks to visit
South Hampton so we haven't been before
but there was a 100 pound charge it'd be
much less likely to and so that's just
one of the campaigns are doing we do a
lot on council tax which is one of the
most hated taxes in Britain because you
have to pay that like it doesn't just
come out of here and come straight away
you have you get a bill and you have to
pay it and that means people are really
ticked off about it and they really care
about how that money is spent and
sometimes it's spent well but more often
than not we find areas where it's not
spent well so where do we do a lot of
things one of the things so you what
you're proposing sounds great my worry
is number one what happens to our public
services I mean let's be fair the NHS
isn't well it doesn't look like it's
doing that well it needs more money the
Rogues are in a horrible state in London
they're talking about cutting police
services crime spiking don't we need
people to pay more tax to pay for these
public services well at the moment
government spendings about 30,000 pounds
per household
so government spending is very very high
there's a lot of money in the kitty and
at them there's billions of pounds being
spent in projects and areas that aren't
essential services so about 14 billion
in foreign aid for example about 56
billion put aside for hs2 which is a
train from Birmingham to London it's
going to make you know this
infrastructure project there's so many
areas of spending that you could cut
and read avert into public services
which is actually something that we
advocate I think there are areas of
spending areas of public public services
that need more money I think social care
is underfunded I think was a huge
mistake to make it separate to the NHS
and then to lock that costume to local
councils so it does need to be funded
I think policing probably needs money to
be spent well and it isn't always spent
well but also they probably need more
funding and when you pay your taxes and
things you think about
it's the NHS it's been collection its
education policing defence and these
areas are areas where actually
government has cut down and spending one
area the government hasn't cut down on
is public sector pensions which costs
about 38 billion a year more than the
education budget in England so I
understand the argument and that
politicians make that we need to put up
tax let's pay public services but you
can't make that argument if you're
spending a lot of money you know on
things that just don't aren't necessary
state-funded art it's not necessary like
if I was a politician and I had to
choose between putting more money into
the health system or spending you know
millions to give it to artist to do
state-funded drawings that go in
galleries that people probably won't
visit because if you can't make money
off your art it's probably not going to
be very popular so can you imagine a
state-funded comedy night you'd have to
fill out a form and say I adhere to
these regulations and and you'd say
actually no you can't make that joke and
it'd be rubbish that's why comedies
going yeah but on public services as
well we're doing a little work on
technology and automation so how
technology can actually improve
particularly the NHS so at the moment
NHS services are using things like
Windows 98 there's been examples of
doctors using whatsapp to share patient
records which isn't just like bad well
it's not the best way of doing things so
there needs to be a lot of reform in
efficiency and that
and we're doing some research on that
what does the aegis really use windows
night yeah that's why it was so it's so
vulnerable to cyberattacks you had that
one a cry was at one acquire want to be
cry attack last year yeah yeah well this
was gonna actually close what it there
must be a few examples that if you just
tell an ordinary person this is what the
government's doing with your money
they've got to be you probably have a
few of those where you kind of go this
is what they do and people go oh you
know freaked out what can you give us a
few examples of something like that well
I think the one that frustrates people
the most is pay for public sector staff
not frontline staff not nurses and
teachers bureaucrats civil servants and
bosses the amount of money that goes
into not just salaries but also bonuses
and payouts for top staff is
extraordinary and because there isn't a
lot of scrutiny over it you just assume
that the government spends money well
right it's only groups at the taxpayers
alliance that kick up a fuss and say
hang on why are you giving a local
government boss a three hundred thousand
pound payer that's twice the salary of
the prime minister something's going
wrong here so that's the one that I
think annoys people the most in our
research that we do every year would do
a report called the townhall Rich List
which is top paid local government chief
executives in the country and quite a
lot of them are earning more than two
reason May which is I thought it was a
good talents really I think it may get
done I was horrible I I nearly had a
heart attack just watching it that
unpleasant yeah III just thought it was
good I can't do better than that
and so I liked it but but it distracted
from you know everything else I think it
was very smart politics was everyone's
talking about her dance they weren't
talking about the fact that she didn't
use the word checkers once in her speech
so it's good polish there you go look
incompetent that's something is supposed
to do and then no one cares that you're
incompetent and what you are doing okay
so so the chief executives get paid more
than Teresa may but still that's not
something like that's that's definitely
gonna piss people off I totally see that
but that's not like a thing that makes
me go oh my god I can't believe that's
happening is it like a thing that we
spend tons of money on that well I mean
hi hey Chester is a big water go so I
mean it's it's so unnecessary it is the
wrong infrastructure project I'm not
against infrastructure projects but this
is so unnecessary it's just a fantasy
project for from George Osborne who
wanted politicians like to say here's my
project I got it done success story what
you've done is he spent a bunch of money
on something that nobody really needs
and at the beginning they said it was
going to be worth any billion now it's
something it could be up to 80 to 100
billion and it's such it's really really
expensive and by the time it's built
it's actually going to be quite outdated
so the main argument they're making is
that it's first they said it was about
speed so we need a train that gets from
London to Birmingham 20 minutes quicker
that was the justification and now
they're saying it's about capacity
another thing it's about jobs because
they're creating lots of jobs because of
lots of PR firms being hired by hate
just to sell to project I'm about 17 PR
firms it's ridiculous and so that that
is one area of spending that if I was
Prime Minister I would cut on day one
because that's a lot that's a lot of
money I mean if you compare it to
education in England that's 33 billion
the entire defense budget it's about 38
billion HS to 60 to 100 billion that's
it's so much money and for something
that is very unpopular and it's actually
ruining people's homes as well so that
to put down the track they've got to
build through a lot of towns and areas
and it's causing a lot of upset and and
we're working really hard we hope that
we can get it scrapped but at the moment
they're saying we've spent 4 billion on
it so far so we might as well waste
another you know 50 60 billion which i
think is a very poor argument and then I
would back any politician who had the
guts to say we got it wrong I'm gonna
I'm gonna save some money now this is
project quangos is another one so
they're generally quango is it's a
non-governmental organization exactly so
it's the NHS is technically a Kroger I
think but it's essentially a publicly
funded organization that isn't really a
government department so public health
England is one of the most famous ones
but there are so many of them there are
so many of them that we don't even have
a list compiled and they cost a lot of
money and they have really expensive
areas for bosses that come in sometimes
ex politicians or people that are
friends of politicians and then they get
a cushy job at a quango and they sit and
write reports all day and that nobody
really reads and so there is quangos for
so many different things a lot of them
are health quangos you could merge them
into say twelve main health quangos and
save so much money and david cameron's
promised a bonfire of quangos when he
came in so he said these are so you know
we have too many we've got hundreds of
quangos we don't need them let's just
you know scrap a lot of them and I think
he cut down like a couple doesn't not
even that but they don't really reach
the headlines in the same way as why do
you think that is white why were they
not able to do that what's what's the
difficulty in getting rid of them or
merging them I just think it wasn't
really a priority there are so many
things that aren't a priority like
simplification of the tax system like
simplifying the tax system would save so
many problems but it would take a long
time it would be very complicated and at
the moment I think there are politicians
of other things in their mind but it's a
shame because there are so many things
that could be improved by either merging
quangos simplifying government you know
getting rid of bureaucracy but then it
isn't the political willpower for it
imagine like that's your political
platform like okay everyone it's gonna
focus on just organizing I'm going to
give the government a spring clean and
just make sure that everything's working
well that's that's not as inspiring as
saying I'm gonna spend all this money on
this project or I'm gonna fund this off
on that but that's the vote winner and
that's why I think Jeremy Corbyn is very
popular he's promising to do things but
those things all cost money and the way
that he wants to fund it is to actually
kind of drain the wealth and the desire
to create wealth in this country which
would be a very bad thing
well don't forget that dig in there you
mentioned the criticism I mean I think
Oh quite often yeah I've done
pro-fascist oh really yeah according to
some a couple of people on the Internet
simultaneously a left-wing cell that's
selling out cut social justice warrior
left-wing cuck Wow who is also in favor
who's pro-fascist and in favor of all at
the same time it is pointing out
deficiencies that even I wasn't aware
yes so well I mean I think in this
country a lot of people use the word
right-wing as an insult and just to mean
bad people but there is a legitimate
kind of right center-right position that
doesn't have to be demonized so when
people talk about the Taxpayers Alliance
being a right-wing organization is that
accurate I think so in in that if
right-wing means less government then
yes there are you know we said we were a
very single issue group wait tax pays
likes doesn't have a position and brags
it or in many other things it just
stands for lower taxes less government
spending and more simpler government
every season yeah yeah I'm the Jeremy
Corbyn there with
yeah I think there's a lot of people who
think that if you also campaign for
lower taxes it means you don't want to
help people or you don't believe in any
kind of public service or government and
that's just not sure at all I think
there are definitely libertarians out
there who support us and who would like
to privatize everything and I wonder who
would build the roads to be honest I'm
but generally most of our activists and
certainly the the team that when we at
the moment we just believe in smaller
government say keep it to the essential
stuff most people just want to pay their
taxes but not too much for good public
services and other than that for the
government to leave them alone so it
sounds like what you really want is just
to eliminate wastes from pretty much
yeah and also just make things run a lot
more smoothly so that's great at
Conservative Party conference we had a
panel on local councils and some put
their hand up and said I used to work in
the private sector and now I I went into
local council to do some work and it was
like walking into a 1970s TARDIS it was
incredible and and I think that's the
reaction of a lot of people that go from
the private or the public sector they
say how how are these processes in place
why does everything take such a slow why
is everything move so slowly
why is there no efficiency wise they
don't get up and go I think we really
need that especially you know with with
brexit a spring-cleaning of government I
think I'm going to use that actually
yeah I like that phrase government is
like a spring clean yeah make it
efficient one thing I always want to ask
people who are involved in tax and it's
just for the average person on the
street and it drives me up the wall and
I'm sure it drives them up the wall why
can't we get big businesses to pay
[ __ ] tax that's very good question
it's because the UK has a really over
complicated tax code it's about eleven
thousand pages long and there are so
many different taxes and tax codes that
if you're an accountant and you search
hard enough you can find a loophole for
just about anything so if you're a
really big company or organization you
can afford a team of accountants and
lawyers to find all the loopholes for
you that's how big companies like like
Amazon and Facebook and multinationals
during
paying as much taxes as smaller
organizations it's completely legal they
find accountants and lawyers to find
holes if you simplify the system and he
said here it is everyone's got to pay
this there are a few exemptions but this
is that these are the rules you wouldn't
they wouldn't be allowed to do that and
this is it really annoys me when
politicians say or we need to crack down
on businesses not paying their fair
share it's in their power like these
companies are avoiding tax completely
legally it's you politician that you to
change the law to make it fairer because
it's not fair that if you're a small
business you can't afford to get an
accountant to find loopholes for you so
you pay your taxes in good faith and
when a larger organization can't afford
to find a loophole it's just it's really
not fair and it means there isn't trust
in the tax system and it means that
people start resenting paying their
taxes because like why am i paying so
much of my my wage or my earnings or my
in a most small profit to the state when
all these larger companies aren't
terribly with you on that so so is since
why don't they change it is it going
back to what you said that actually is
because it's too complex and it's too
difficult it doesn't capture the
public's imagination oh is it a part of
it there's a more sinister reason I
don't want to think as I sinister reason
I'd like to believe that it's just
because it's not a priority but maybe I
don't know I'm not privy to backroom
conversations I know that there is a big
problem with corporatism at the moment
in the West and that you do have
companies with larger GDPs and country's
huge organizations and once you get to a
certain size you almost don't want a
free market you don't want it to be easy
for your competition to enter the market
so you do cozy up with the EU or
bureaucrats in Whitehall to try and get
the rules written so there are more
regulations and more barriers to entry
that would be in your interests and I
think at the moment people distrust
business and capitalism because they see
that happening and that's that's not
right that's not free that's not a
proper free market that's corporatism
and that's not really what I stand for
and where do you stand on the tax raise
because you've talked about eliminating
waste but you've also said that people
pay too much tax so is
argument that we eliminate hs2 we
eliminate quangos or you know cut down
the number of quangos we eliminate other
things that you've talked about then
just by virtue of that the tax rates can
come down or is it really about reducing
the tax load on people altogether in
addition to those things so that we
would have less money for other things
for public services and whatever you'd
have to do both then you'd have to do it
gradually so you'd want to lower taxes
gradually and also cut down on spending
bit by bit
I'm a you know big fan of the do it now
a little bit and wait and see because I
think if we did lower with some taxes
you'd find you get more revenue in so
when corporation tax was lowered the
government had more more revenue because
you know more people were paying and it
was more of an incentive to pay so I
think if you did lower taxes you you may
find that there's more money in the
economy and things grow more and you do
have more revenue but like all economics
it really is disputed and I'm not an
economist by it by any standard but we
had some researchers on this to work out
all of these problems in a single income
tax which I spoke about which was you
know sitting down and seriously thinking
what would you need to cut what would
you need what would be a long-term plan
to get to that optimum point of spending
and taxation and it's a really really
good document and I'd encourage anyone
who's who is I'm sure but what we stand
for to actually read that because
they're very practical measures and we
actually have a thing on our website
where you could go through and test how
much you would cut so a list of things
like of spending you could cut so like
state funded art or foreign aid or you
know hs2 and it would show you how much
spending decrease so it showed you how
much you could afford to cut taxes by or
how much money you'd be saving and that
what that was very cool
but I don't think it would be as simple
as just clicking your fingers get rid of
some waste and lower taxes I think it'd
be difficult and had to be gradual but
it would it would make people's lives
living standards a lot better because I
think when you put money in people's and
businesses hands they spend it a lot
better than the government
and actually when you leave it to people
to solve problems they're pretty good at
it so you have the government failing in
some areas so the rollout of universal
credits and then the Community Food
Bank's that Russell tries to charity
set up by individuals in the community
come in and solve that problem and I
think that's a really good thing it's
interesting so you've you've talked
about some of the kind of I mean all the
things you're saying you may or may not
agree with them but there are reasonable
things right these are conversations
that can be had reasonably right I think
this is what taxes should be no I
disagree I think this is what taxes
should be I want to go to Berman 20
minutes faster I don't really know I
want to leave Birmingham 20 we've lost
all that so these are conversations that
you can have there's two reasonable
people and have a reasonable
disagreement about right so where does
the vitriol come from that you've kind
of referenced that people push back on
it people call you Nazis and whatever
why is that why do you think ask a
question I wish I knew because then
maybe I could stop it I wish I knew why
people were so negative towards us and
as a spokesperson what if it's just
directed at me so I'm using a bit of a
punching bag sometimes we have a lot of
activists who are afraid of putting
themselves out there for that reason I
think I'm not sure if it's just a left
problem but at the moment particularly
online there is a very strong left-wing
hates mob that descend on you if you
publicly say things that I'm saying and
even if you are perfectly reasonable in
your arguments and you do try to explain
yourself I think there's a barrier to
accepting that any reasonable person
could not be a socialist so as soon as
you are to the right of Jeremy Corbyn
it's assumed that you're an evil person
and what I've found is you're
dehumanized and so you don't does the I
think they think you don't really
deserve the respect or courtesy as a
normal person because if you're right
when you're evil so I don't need to
engage in your arguments in your ideas
because you
evil person and so it's okay for me to
send you nasty messages and tell you to
go back to where you came from and all
that kind of rubbish I think as well the
Internet has a big part to play in this
I don't know if they'd say this to my
face I don't know if people would say
the things I say on Twitter to anyone's
face so maybe I mean I try to it is
helpful but when I read them I try to
think well this person's probably just
having a bad day and and I'm taking the
brunt of it a bad year they can kind of
be like football team like I'm on this
side and you're on that side so it's
gonna feel good to have a go at you it's
kind of tribalism and people on the
right do it as well like I think a lot
of left-wing commentators and
politicians get so much nastiness online
and it is very tribal because I have
friends who are very left-wing and
they're really good people and I think
we just disagree it's true there are
exceptions
yeah and we don't take that kind of
we're not right-wing I'm probably more
centrist Francis slightly left but what
troubles us is this tribalism because it
prevents genuine conversation you know
that that's the issue for us so whether
I agree with you or not to me is much
less important than whether we actually
have a genuine conversation and have
that ability to exchange ideas and
exchange information and I think that's
much more important and like you said I
think online you know like we we
actually did a whole video of all the
comments that people send us yeah
whether that just like straight up
racist companies all kinds of stuff and
it is quite funny you know as comedians
we're used to dealing with it so we
don't take it personally but I can
totally see that if you're trying to do
something you're trying to make change
the society and whatever and you just
get hundreds of messages of people just
being nasty to you that's a different
thing you know and it's very it's very
unfortunate that that happens and like
you said I think it happens on both
sides it's not a right or a left thing
but it ties into another thing that we
wanted to just have a chat about as well
which is the free speech thing which is
you know you mentioned that you were
concerned about free speech on campus on
things like that what is what did you
want to
say on that issue I'm just really
concerned that fear of offence and fear
of what people will say about you is
stopping genuine authentic conversation
and expression so I'm concerned that
particularly universities young people
are told that they've got to be you know
really careful about what they say or
they'll go no platform door band or you
know I'm just I'm concerned about that I
don't know what the solution is
I don't know if you know this is
something that it's as prevalent as
perhaps the media make it out to be
maybe there's a bit of hype around it
but I really hope that in our education
system we can teach people to have
authentic conversations like I was very
blessed to go to a philosophy College
where the whole point was that you
discuss ideas and not you know
identities or take sides or anything and
you were trained to be able to see 12
different sides of an argument and I
don't think there's enough of that now I
think as a demonization of the other I
think there is a lot of good versus evil
rhetoric going on where it's you know
you've got to have your beliefs and your
good and the other person's evil
although it's been a little while since
I've been to university so I'm not sure
if that is the case I don't know if if
you have any views on that but it's just
something that I'm concerned about
because I'm seeing all these stories
about people being no platforms or
someone going to do a talk at university
about something very known on
controversial but they're a bunch of
protesters show up and it's shut down
and I'm just I'm concerned if that's the
future these are the people that are
going to go into the world of work next
if that's a healthy way to have society
and I see it happening in politics as
well actually it's a lot of good versus
evil you know the kind of debates on TV
we you have six minutes to discuss an
issue and you've got a variety and a
leftie and someone's got to win and
they've both put up a video saying I
owned the other person and it's not
about maybe we can have a discussion and
learn something about each other or
maybe the viewers can learn something
new it's I need to be you
you're evil and I'm good I think the
worrying thing that I find ultimately
well I have the discussions to listen to
somebody's point of view and then go oh
yeah I never thought like that yeah I
kind of agree with that and then what it
becomes his adversary one ultimately
it's just about display of ego and
that's what you see a lot of the time
whether it's question time or anything
else and that's why you know that we
said before I think when we started this
show is that's why we said this up well
we set this up because it once you get
to that point then it's not about the
shared the expression of ideas and it's
not about sharing ideas and it's not
about learning and it's just about you
know the glorification of that's where
we end up unfortunately yeah you've been
on question time actually how did you
find I have
oh I'm sorry nervous the whole week I
was so scared and then I can do this and
you can do it your accent your tattoo
carefully cultivated image my earth it's
great it's working for you yeah so you
are you a nervous in your mind and then
backstage they have lots of snacks and
drinks but no really touches it because
you're all so nervous mmm-hmm and then I
you go through and you sit down and it
was strange as soon as I sat down and
looked at the audience I thought it's a
bit more calm and I I kind of noted to
myself I said okay I'm just gonna answer
some questions now and didn't really
notice the Camerons and it was a huge
rush it was really exciting so the show
I'd watched so much and shouted out and
said oh if only I was you know up there
I'm it's harder than that looks though
so I didn't watch the whole thing back
but I remembered there's a question on
Corbin and I froze and I didn't say
a authentically what I really thought I
just thought of something on the spot
and I wish I could go back and redo that
bit but that's part of the show I
suppose it's live and you've got to be
really quick on your feet but it was a
really good experience
and yeah you got all the people
afterwards saying nasty things about you
but what was really exciting was people
getting in touched and saying oh you
made me think about this a little bit
differently or hi I'm also a young
person and I hadn't really thought about
the fact that I'm getting taxed so much
you know that sucks I looked at my
paycheck and there's a lot of it going
to the government and that was why I
wanted to go on I wanted to change some
wines or offer a bit of any perspective
[Music]
because you sort of alluded to it and
you were saying you don't agree because
I mean there's a very healthy chance I
mean what they were talking they were
going to have an election in November
and I mean we could still have an
election the next year or so there's a
chance he could be Prime Minister why do
you think that would not be a good thing
for this country
I think his ideas are wrong I think
they're really really problem like
everyone talks about him personally and
his I don't know him personally I don't
know what his morals are for all I know
he has very good intentions I'm not
gonna make any statements about his
character but his ideas and his plans
are very wrong and I think they'd cause
a lot of misery actually for people here
and it would be a very very bad thing
for the country and in it in a way that
I don't think I can articulate what you
know well enough I you know the the idea
of central planning and centralized
control and the state seizing control of
everything it's very very dangerous and
it's not just dangerous because you're
disempowering people of their liberty
because you can say well yes I'll lose
my freedom and my ability to choose but
at least the services are running well
they don't run well when things are run
centrally from a government or from it
would be from Whitehall you get
shortages and things don't run very
smoothly and that's exactly what we saw
in Venezuela and I know that it's kind
of used as an example of socialism gone
wrong and then social say well that's
not real socialism
every single track time central planning
has been tried in the States is in
control of of industry has been tried
it's resulted in mass misery and I think
it comes from a place of compassion
initially you want to help people and it
sounds so simple when it's going to take
all the stuff and make sure it's a
stupid fairly but it really doesn't work
because the people distributing them are
just people and you replace one
hierarchy so free markets and people
making money and getting further up with
another hierarchy where it's a
bureaucrats at the top and there's
always corruption and it's always a bad
thing and in the UK there was a little
bit of central planning in the 70s and
it was getting there's a very big state
and Margaret Thatcher came in and really
she talked yes really she really just
shook it up and she said no we're going
to we're gonna really change things and
what's interesting is when she did that
the people that oppose a lot of her
free-market reforms and most was the
British aristocracy because suddenly it
was going to be a little playing field
working-class kids were going to start
competing with them for jobs and they
were going to have to up their game and
and suddenly you know wealth was
something that you didn't just get
because you were born to the right
family it was something you could earn
and be a part of and I think we should
do for this country was fantastic and I
would hate to see all of that going to
go to waste to go back in time to that
bad failed experiment of central
planning and socialism
I think free free markets are the best
thing to a meritocratic hierarchy that
we have and that's a very good thing for
people and I'm not sure how far call
Mary McDonald would go with what they
really want to do because we know
there's a labor manifesto and they are
hardcore socialist but the manifesto was
a bit less radical right I don't know if
they would just implement that or if
they would go all the way but I know
that they want to go all the way and if
they can get away with that they will I
think that would be a really bad thing I
think all of the Christians about Corbin
is completely as a bit misguided because
it's kind of like Trump like there were
all these stories about his character
and
you know Hillary Clinton said he's a
terrible man people didn't care they
just want to change and I think the
Conservatives you know attacking Coburn
at the moment they're all focusing on
you know this thing he did all that
thing he did and it's people switch off
to that because all they know is
whatever he could be a terrible person
but he's promising change and at the
moment I don't think the Conservative
Party or promising
real solutions people's problems right
now I think they're offering more of the
same and I think that the free market
solution is better but it's not being
advocated very well right now and that's
why this the kind of left-wing socialist
ideas are coming back into fashion it's
funny when you said Jeremy Corbyn is
like Trump I thought we had an actually
your point I think is exactly right
which is that whatever someone's ideas
in the absence of a compelling competing
narrative change will always trump the
status quo if people are not happy with
the status quo and I think that explains
and what I really liked about what he
said there as well as that whether you
like Jeremy Corbyn or not you you're
quite happy to go well I don't know him
he might be a really nice guy but I
don't agree with his ideas and so much
of our politics now seems to be about
attacking the person attacking the man
we've seen this with you know this
judicial appointment in America with
Brett Kavanaugh he's been all about like
his judicial record pretty much didn't
get talked about at all and it's all
about certain allegations which may or
may not be true it's the same with
Donald Trump you know we when we think
about Donald Trump we don't think about
policy I think most people would
struggle to name a single policy other
than build the wall yeah that's your so
it's all about personalities now it is
and I think that that's not a good thing
no I understand when people want to vote
for people that they like so I don't
have anything against politicians being
charismatic or likeable or yeah I mean I
don't think he's that charismatic
actually I was being sucked
you know who was charismatic Jeffrey Cox
did you see the speech he made at
conference no it was brilliant it was so
entertaining he the Attorney General no
one knew he was and he got up and did
this rousing speech in like a Mufasa
voice when he said we need not fear
self-government anyway getting
sidetracked um but I think the issue in
politics now is that people are basing
their political beliefs on identities so
I identify as this kind of person
therefore I've got a vote this way and
it's less about the manifestos and the
policies it's it's more about
personality and identity I think that
gets in the way of proper discussion so
even though maybe if people didn't know
the organization that I work for for
example and they heard me speak an
argument and I said you know we should
change this policy maybe then listen
more than if I was introduced as this is
Chloe from a right-wing think-tank
because I think as soon as you do that
certain amount of people just switch off
and go oh she's evil
and I'm a good because I love the state
there's too much for that I was actually
going to ask you in terms of identity
you're a conservative woman I hope I
haven't missed gender do that so what's
that like question I'm not a member of
the Conservative Party I mean it's my
secret yeah they're closest to my to my
views I think I'm more of a liberal but
not in the the left-wing sense I'm more
of a liberal liberal but I don't think
anyone is just one thing but yeah I am
I'm a right-wing conservative woman it's
difficult because you kind of don't
really always get the approval of your
side be your side because sometimes I
speak about you know inequality or you
know unconscious bias and it's difficult
sometimes in certain industries being a
woman or there's discrimination and then
I'm said oh you know get over it and but
then I don't get the defensive the
feminists because I'm right-wing so I'm
not really a person so when people are
sending me very sexist comments you know
there's there's very little outrage or
sympathy
because I all she deserves it because
she's evil because she wants to lower
taxes so it's it's so it's alright I
don't think it dominates my career
though the fact that I am a conservative
woman or there are more women most of my
days been talking about taxes which is
not gendered right taxpayers women both
men and women pay taxes so I'm curious
you mentioned about are kind of annoying
your side yeah I don't like to call it
that yeah but yeah well yeah I know what
you mean people who would otherwise be
aligned with what you're saying yes they
get annoyed by you talking about
inequality or so what is it that you the
way you differ from the kind of
mainstream narrative on that side of
things in terms of when you talk about
women's issues or whatever what is it
that you say that annoys them yeah I'm
not sure if it annoys them but I'm
definitely definitely honest about what
I think about things and put Amelie on
Twitter I'll say what I really think and
sometimes people think it's a bit
strange so you know talk about why you
know it's it's not fair that sometimes
women in politics I judged unfairly for
how they look at how they dress and I'll
be told to you know grow up by some
people and told well let's stop
complaining you're a right wing woman so
you support the patriarchy and so I
can't really have an opinion on social
issues without people bringing my
economic beliefs into it if that makes
sense and I'd say that I'm probably
aligned with a lot of young people and
most issues I'm you know pretty the
bateria I think I'm coming around to
drug legalization I think I'm right is a
great thing I'm pro-choice and these a
lot of issues that I think it's not so
young people agree with me but because I
think taxes should be lower there's a
perception that I'm supposed to be
really conservative and social issues
too so one plate one way you differ from
a lot of young people statistically is
brixon yeah and that you are progress it
you believe it's a good idea um I think
I'm statistically a majority of young
people are anti breaks if you just
explain I'm not sure what you
it will be a positive thing for this
country I think I'd be a great thing I
sort of really really do at the moment
although the conversations are about how
we leave and the technicalities of the
deal but the reason people voted Lee was
what could be achieved outside of the EU
and it was really about who makes
decisions in this country is it going to
be the EU that makes decisions about
policy or elected politicians in the UK
and that is essentially what it came
down to you whether your left or right
wing the decisions been made in
Westminster now and so you have more
power and more influence over
decision-making then when those
decisions are made in the European
Commission so I think they're a
fantastic thing but I appreciate not all
young people agree with me what's
interesting though is when you break it
down by social class working-class young
people about forty-five percent rated
leave so in the referendum yes age was a
big determining factor but also
geography and income was also was
another big factor wealthier people were
to remain unless well-off people tended
to vote leave more as I said we had a
guest on the show whose episode may or
may not release before or after yours
eric cartman is a professor of politics
at Birkbeck university and he's just
really he's just publishing a book now
where he talks about his analysis of the
individual level of the reasons that
people vote for brexit and actually he
shows that income was not a big factor
and the biggest factor was attitudes to
immigration essentially and he's not by
the way using that narrative that
everyone who voted leave as a racist at
all but that was the biggest predictor
of voting to leave so I think the elite
the cutting the intellectual elite might
have been concerned about getting our
powers back from Brussels or whatever
but actually I think this was I was
going to put you the the main predictor
of voting to leave was social attitudes
particularly to immigration right so
what do you make of that
counter-argument that's really
interesting well I can only go based on
anecdotal evidence and people that I
spoke to you on the campaign and it was
more of a gut instinct that decisions
should be made here now I want my
governments being control of that
whether it's immigrant
no trade or whatever I know the
immigration played a really huge part in
that what was interesting is after the
referendum open Europe did a really big
extensive report into attitudes and
immigration in the UK what people really
think and what they found was that most
people just wanted immigration to be
controlled and fair and they didn't
really have a problem it wasn't about
numbers it was more about the fact that
Britain didn't have control over
immigration that was a really big
concern and what's interesting is that
the most popular replacement immigration
system is the Australian skills-based
system that we have in Australia and we
have higher levels of immigration per
capita but it isn't immigration isn't
really an election issue it's not as
much of a political issue because people
have trust in the system the government
controls it and we know it's fair and I
think if you had that system in the UK
where people knew okay all the
governments regulating this and you know
it's it's based on on visas and and work
and it's not based on whether someone's
European or not I think there'd be a lot
more positive towards immigration
I think infrastructure is a huge problem
so housing people became I think they
felt like Britain was becoming not to
full but public services were getting
very busy and there's enough houses and
what's interesting this has been pointed
out to me by free-market people who are
very Pro free movement and they say to
me well the market is able to respond to
changes in population so Tesco always
has enough food people private service
has always do it's the public services
the government services that don't
really keep up with changes to
population so you know free movement
isn't a bad thing Chloe it's just that
the government hasn't been able to get
the NHS to speed up and creating more
you know hospitals and infrastructure
and the like and I think that's probably
the case but just because just because
there is in a perfect world a
free-market way of having free movement
I don't think that's an argument for it
to happen now because we live in the
real world
the UK were actually infrastructure
isn't keeping up with demand we don't
have a government that is keeping up
with demand and people are really
struggling and suffering now under the
the weight of that but what was
interesting during the referendum is
that I was an immigrant campaigning for
brexit and I'd love to prefer that very
interesting and I think yeah I moved
here I want to live here permanently
this is my country and for me it was a
lot more about the future of Britain
than immigration policy but I personally
found it very unfair that people from
Nonnie new countries were discriminated
against in favor of those from any
countries so you had an open-door policy
with some people based on whether born
and a closed policy on others based
mother for one thing it's actually very
discriminatory in xenophobic and it's
it's not the best way to have an
immigration system but why do people
vote leave I mean that is the question
that everyone asks and it's a
million-dollar question and I'd be
interested in reading that report it was
a big thing but it wasn't the only thing
and what I found in it Dona Lee and you
know since after her friend and speak a
little leave activist it was just about
control it was just about I want the
British government to be in control of
these things these are things that
should be done by a national government
not a multinational organization that I
have no access or power to lobby or or
change things all right well listen
times almost up it's been so great to
have you on thanks for coming to talk to
us the question we always like to ask at
the end is what is the one thing that
we're not talking about that we ought to
be talking about
Automation I think yeah shocking I think
automation is going to change society
it's gonna change the world it's gonna
change how we live our lives and it's
gonna if we don't plan for it I mean it
could be a really really good thing but
it's going to completely change
everything automated cars or don't need
jobs becoming automated and we should be
talking about and planning for that now
thanks a lot all right listen thanks
very much for coming on it's been
absolute pleasure to
to have you on the show as always if you
enjoyed it this week click that Bell
button next to subscribe button once
you've clicked the subscribe button of
course subscribe to us on iTunes and
SoundCloud follow us Francis that
trigger trigger pod follow us on
Instagram Twitter go on our Facebook
leave a nice comment in so constant and
do whatever you wanted there alright
guys thanks for watching listening
whatever else and we'll see you next
week